we've got a voicemail number you can
call that number any time of day if it's
3 a.m. and you want to call you can call
and many people do call it 3 a.m. those
messages are sometimes a little bit more
unusual than the ones we get it's sort
of more normal times of day here's an
interesting voicemail someone called
asking a question the question was
whether they would be able to ask
questions I guess some subsequent future
point or something like that take a
listen to this I'm not gonna let me I
got a serious question for y'all about
political and stuff thank you have a
nice a listen this is John from Abilene
Texas and John from other okay uh to
answer John's question we will accept
any and all questions about political I
mean well he could have just asked the
question
political is fine but stuff I don't know
about stuff stuff we don't want things I
will accept questions are good stuff I
don't ya ask the question that's what
the voicemail number is here for can I
ask you a question yeah okay you can
call live as well I would actually
rather hear from John live next time we
take phone calls we do announce that on
Twitter twitter.com slash david pakman
show and people by the way pat loving
last week's phone calls where we had an
unhinged trumpet call young we had a a
progressive woman who is married to a
trump supporter who admitted that his
being a trump supporter has caused
intimacy issues and their lot evenly as
though reluctantly so but she did admit
to that so I I expect that calls are
going to only get better this week so
stay tuned later in the week to 192
david p is the voicemail number we've
got a tremendous bonus show for you
today a famed R&B singer and alleged
urine fetishist are kelly is accused of
holding women in a cult-like situation
according to what parents are telling
police delta and ann coulter have had a
big spat over something delta believes
is worth thirty dollars and something
Ann Coulter believes is worth ten
thousand dollars of her time so we will
see whether they can come together on
either in the middle on some kind of
value there
and we will also determine Pat recently
alleged that he has one to two cups of
coffee per week I believe that his giant
thermos contains way more than one to
two cups of coffee and we will actually
measure it out on today's bonus show and
determine whether Pat will be able to
weather this scandal a david pakman.com
slash membership sign up and get instant
access to the bonus show you can use the
coupon code I voted 17 for a 40%
discount and by all means keep the
patreon pledges coming we are
approaching 1800 patreon pledges
patreon.com slash david pakman shows the
website that's PA tre1 com slash david
pakman show I will speak to you on the
bonus show